Narrator: Tonight on
"Shark Tank," Kendra Scott,
the founder of
billion‐dollar jewelry brand
Kendra Scott,
returns to the Tank.
I have over 2,000 women
that work for me.
I'm the Guru of Gouda,
the Master of Mozzarella,
and Sultan of Swiss.
It solves the problem
every pet owner has.
The entire process
of getting ready
is all about to change.
I would love
to work with you, but...
We're gonna do over
$4 million this year.
‐Whoo!
You're crushing it!
I can't be
your queen bee here.
If you disappoint
your customer, you've lost.
This is ‐‐ This is ‐‐
No.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a healthier version
of a favorite beauty item.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
How are you?
My name is
Anika Goodwin Hilderbrand,
and I live in Greensboro,
North Carolina.
I am the head diva in charge
of OpulenceMD Beauty,
and I am here seeking
$75,000
in exchange for 5%
of my company.
Sharks, don't you love
my eyelashes?
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I love everything.
They're fake.
[ Chuckles ]
These days, Kevin,
lashes are the new boobs.
Every woman wants
a bigger, better pair.
[ Laughter ]
It's not ‐‐
As much as I love
wearing lash extensions,
I suck at putting them
on correctly.
And worse, it bothers me
that I'm using harmful chemicals
like formaldehyde
near my eyes.
Did you know that most eyelash
extensions on the market
are applied using
the same adhesive
used in superglue?
After years of eyelash abuse
and losing my own lashes
and walking around looking
like a hairless Chihuahua...
[ Laughs ]
...I decided,
"Enough is enough.
There has to be
a better way."
So I created
OpulenceMD Beauty.
It's a luxury beauty brand
specializing in eyelash
extension products
that take the trial,
the error,
and the harmful ingredients
out of the process.
I have created
an eyelash extension
that is noticeably lighter,
more comfortable,
and amazingly easy to apply.
So, Sharks, don't blink on
this opportunity of a lifetime.
Your time to get involved
on this great deal may be short,
but your lashes
should never be.
Wow.
[ Laughs ]
Great pitch.
Thank you.
I have personally chosen
lashes for each of you.
I can't wait
to see mine!
So, I have a video
that will show you
how this is applied.
You first apply
the magnetic liner.
It has tiny
iron oxide particles,
and then, the lash
just pops into place
because of the magnets
on the band.
Wait, wait.
This is the liner?
That's it.
You want to try it?
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so, what is
the meaning of OpMD?
I am an eye surgeon.
I am an ophthalmologist.
You are. Okay.
And so, specifically,
an eyelid specialist.
That's my specialty.
That adds a little bit more
credibility to this story.
Wow, yes.
It sure does.
Corcoran: Enormous.
I do eyelid procedures,
tumors, fractures ‐‐
those sorts of things.
That is my specialty.
How'd I do, Anika?
Mark, I love it!
Greiner: Let me see.
Oh, my gosh!
Did you do it?
[ Laughter ]
If I can do it...
You did amazing!
How does it feel, Mark?
Oh.
Think you're gonna
keep wearing it?
Hey, it's the new
boobs, right?
My boobs are getting bigger,
so my eyelashes
have got to get bigger.
Oh, my goodness.
Greiner:
Back to a question.
So, I'm familiar
with this space.
Do you have
a patent on this?
I do not have a patent,
and I did not create
magnetic liner and lashes.
Okay.
What I did was
basically build
a better mousetrap.
I created a lash
that is weightless.
You feel like
there's nothing there.
But they typically
will stay all day?
All day.
Like, I wouldn't be
in a meeting,
and all of a sudden, I'd have
a cattywonkus eyelash on my ‐‐
Nope.
Okay.
You can exercise in 'em.
You can nap in them.
Are these reusable?
Up to 40 uses.
Really?
Yes, up to 40 uses,
so it's much more economical
than the traditional
lash with glue
that you can get maybe five or
six wears out of, at the most.
So, if I was ‐‐
You know, Anika, may I say,
these look so very real.
They're not too heavy.
Most eyelashes I could
spot eight feet away.
Yes.
These are so delicate.
They look like real ‐‐
It's by design.
What are they
made out of?
They're made of mink.
Most of the lashes in
my collections are made of mink.
What about the minks?
How do they feel about it?
The hairs actually come
from the tail of the mink.
It's totally cruelty free.
You brush through the mink's
tail, and that's how the ‐‐
No minks are harmed
in the making of this product.
No minks are harmed.
You're worried
about that?
I'm one with minks.
Oh, yeah.
So, how did you go
from doing eye surgery
to designing eyelashes?
Well, I am not
your typical doctor.
I love to look nice,
and lashes, for me, have always
helped me feel more confident.
I went through a period
in my life
where I lost my mom and my dad
39 days apart.
Oh, my gosh.
Greiner: Sorry.
I lost my marriage of 15 years
three months after that.
No.
And I've always
been confident,
but I really struggled
with my confidence
during that time.
Who wouldn't? My God.
Yes.
And the last year's
helped me a lot,
so I don't want you
to just think of this
as a lash company.
I look at this as a way
for professional women
to own whatever room
they come in
because they are exuding
that much confidence.
So, mink lashes
are the most expensive.
They are.
So, how much
does this cost?
So, the set that you have
would run about $245...
Hello!
Whoa!
...for the entire set.
That's a surprise!
O'Leary: 245 bucks?!
Wow.
I can buy
my own mink for that.
What's your total cost
for this package, to make it?
My total cost for that package
is about $20.
Wow!
My margins are
around 88% to 95%.
But how much
are you selling?
I launched this company
in February.
In that time frame,
my sales are $685,000.
Wow!
In February of this year?
O'Leary: Whoa!
February of this year.
You're crushing it!
That's killing it!
Scott: What?!
And what are you
using as your mode
in which to get
the word out?
Are you on Instagram ads,
Facebook ads?
Yes, I am
paid advertising,
but a lot of education
and community building.
This is not just
selling lashes for me.
This is an opportunity
to tell and help women
learn how to take care
of their eyes
and make better decisions
for their vision.
Corcoran:
Have you made money?
'Cause your cost's
very high.
I was profitable
as of last month.
Last month,
I did $213,000.
All online.
Cuban: Hello!
Your margins are incr‐‐
Scott: And your competition
sells for what?
You're not the first person
to come on "Shark Tank"
with lashes, okay?
I know I'm not.
But you're the first one
to have incredible margins.
I think I can get
the mink community behind it.
Look at them closely, Anika.
"The mink community."
"The mink community"?
The mink community is very
concerned about their tails.
I think I can
solve that problem.
Yes, very concerned.
Yes.
Anika, you know,
as much now as I am ‐‐
as Kevin would say,
I am one with the lash,
it's not really my forte.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out, but congratulations.
Before you go out, Mark,
I have one thing to say.
So, a percentage
of all of our proceeds
goes back to helping people
who could not otherwise afford
to get eye screening exams.
Oh, that's nice.
Love that.
Good for you.
Wow.
Corcoran: One more
question, if I may.
You're presenting
such an ideal picture,
but you must
have a challenge.
I do.
Let's hear about that.
Fulfillment
is my challenge.
Well, that's not a problem.
That's a blessing.
I have grown so quickly,
it is very difficult ‐‐
I'm having trouble
keeping up with fulfillment.
So, what would you use
the Shark's cash for?
What I really need
from you, Sharks ‐‐
I need the cash,
but I really need help
with the back end.
Right now, the only reason
my margins aren't even higher
is because I am paying
so many contractors.
I would love to be able
to have access
to your back end,
to your teams.
You're saying
the supply chain?
In other words, you want help
in assembly and distribution?
Right.
Anika, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out,
but Kevin is interested
in Anika's healthier fake
eyelash company, OpulenceMD.
♪♪
Anika, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
♪♪
I'll give you
the $75,000 for 20%.
Okay.
You've got an offer.
Those are
fantastic numbers.
Okay, unlike
Mr. Wonderful,
I know a lot about this.
O'Leary: I am wearing
eyeliner right now.
I know a lot about this.
I wear eyeliner.
I look spectacular.
And I will tell you,
at first, I was like,
"Oh, I've seen this
out here in the market."
I did not think I was
going to be interested
in giving you an offer.
And meeting you,
I'm so impressed.
First of all,
I think that you do
have something
very different
than what I've seen
out there ‐‐
that you have you
and your expertise
and your knowledge
of being a doctor.
Yes.
And that goes
a long way for people,
especially when you're putting
something near your eyes.
Yes.
I would feel much better
purchasing this
knowing that an eye doctor
is endorsing it
and creating
these products.
Yes.
I also run a business,
and I have over 2,000 women
that work for me.
My company,
we're over 96% women.
I am on Zoom calls all day
with these fabulous women ‐‐
with my
Kendra Scott family ‐‐
and let me tell you,
they've got their lashes on.
Yes, they do.
They've got
their jewelry on.
We are all neck‐up
right now in this world...
Right, right.
This is important.
And this ‐‐ We want to
look good, right?
Yes.
And we want to feel good
about ourselves.
We want to feel good.
And you're right.
Lashes do just kind of like
brighten up the face.
They do.
So, I'm gonna match
his offer at 20%.
♪♪
I would love
to work with you,
but I'd like to counter.
Okay.
Would you do
$75,000 for...
...12%?
Hmm.
♪♪
What if I give you
$100,000 for 20%?
♪♪
Would you do
$125,000 for 20%?
Geez, you're just ‐‐ you know,
you're coming up ‐‐
I think $100,000 for 20%.
I'm gonna stick with that.
♪♪
Yes.
Oh, my God!
Cuban:
Good job.
So excited!
That does it.
The mink community
is gonna hear about this.
[ Laughs ]
I am so excited!
I'm so thrilled!
I am, too.
I can't wait!
[ Laughs ]
Yeeeeeeees!
Whoo!
[ Exhales deeply ]
♪♪
[ Inhales deeply ]
[ Sighs ]
[ Voice breaking ] My parents
would be so proud right now.
[ Inhales quickly ]
[ Sighs ]
I wish they could be here
to see it.
[ Sniffles, sighs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Earlier this season,
Sarah Apgar made a deal
with Daniel Lubetzky
for FitFighter,
a line of innovative
strength‐training tools.
I think you have
incredible potential.
Co‐captain Daniel Lubetzky!
Whoo!
You got a deal.
Narrator:
Let's see what she's up to now.
Apgar: Come on, here we go!
As an Army veteran
and a volunteer firefighter,
I invented the Steelhose to
train firefighters to be better.
We began to realize
this was for everyone
who's needing strength,
conditioning,
and who has an everyday mission.
Prior to "Shark Tank,"
I did $45,000 in sales.
In just one week
following "Shark Tank,"
we had $250,000 in sales.
Now, just three months later,
we have
almost $900,000 in sales.
Bring it back and come down.
We put together
an on‐demand training platform
that also includes
live training.
It feels incredible
that we have thousands
of new people
that are benefiting
from this new strength training.
We're very excited right now
that we've got FitFighter
online,
so people can get the product
everywhere.
Dick's is a big deal
for Sarah and FitFighter.
It's one of the foremost leaders
in health and wellness,
and now
she's gonna have her product
across hundreds of stores
nationwide.
Aah, I'm so excited!
Apgar:
Through Dick's Sporting Goods
and other retail partners,
we will be receiving $250,000
in new purchase orders.
We knew
we had something special here,
both in the product
and in Sarah,
and so we are just really,
really excited
to be in the early innings
of this one.
Alright, teammates.
I would tell any young girl,
entrepreneur, service member,
when you have a big dream,
seize that moment
because dreams
really do come true,
and that's something
worth fighting for.
A donation of $20,000.
Lubetzky: One of the things
I love about Sarah
is that she likes to give back.
So when she told us that
she was going to donate $10,000
to the Tunnel to Towers
Foundation
benefiting firefighters,
we were very honored
to match it,
and we hope to continue serving
that community
that is always risking
their lives to keep us safe.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a better way to cut the cheese.
♪♪
Howdy, Sharks.
My name is Tate Koenig.
I'm the Guru of Gouda,
the King of Colby‐Jack,
the Bad Boy of Brie,
Master of Mozzarella,
and Sultan of Swiss,
aka "Mr. Cheese."
[ Laughter ]
Now, if you love cheese
as much as me,
it's not a question of,
"To cheese, or not to cheese,"
but rather, "What kind of cheese
do you please?"
The block or preprocessed,
sliced or grated?
[ Laughs ]
The block is more affordable
and higher quality,
but we all know
getting that perfect slice ‐‐
it's no easy feat.
And afterwards,
it usually ends up
in some janky plastic bag,
oversized storage container,
or single‐use plastic wrap
you throw away after each use.
If you do go with
the preprocessed,
sliced or grated,
it's more convenient, sure,
but it costs way more,
and it comes covered
in all of those gross
anti‐clumping agents.
Ugh!
[ Laughs ]
I've solved all
of these issues and then some
with the Cheese Chopper,
the "great" new way to slice,
[grate]
shred, and store your cheese
with ease.
The Cheese Chopper
comes equipped
with three handle options
to help you "cut the cheese."
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
You have a wire...
I wanted to use that line.
...for your perfect,
thin slices,
the blade to chop right
through your hard cheeses,
and the grater for all
of your shredding desires.
Wow.
The cheese
adjustment wheel
gives you perfect
cheese control,
so it doesn't matter if you like
your slices thick or thin ‐‐
you get the perfect slice
every time.
The Cheese Chopper is fun.
It's safe.
If that's not
"Gouda 'nough"...
[ Laughter ]
...the snap‐on airtight seal
keeps your cheese fresh
for an "un‐Brie‐lievably"
long time.
I'm seeking $75,000
for 10% of my company.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to start making some cheddar?
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
Kendra, unless you have
something "feta" to do,
would you like to come up here
and chop some cheese?
I would love to co‐‐
How did you know
that I like cheese?
Cuban: Who knew you liked ‐‐
Everyone loves cheese!
Come on!
Everybody loves cheese.
I was born in
the diary state.
I'm a Wisconsin‐‐
Oh, I'm well aware.
I've been doing
a lot of research.
So I can come up and taste?
I'm so excited.
Yeah, so, if you want to
come over here.
Okay.
That one over there
is for you.
Oh, this side. Okay.
So, it's really simple
and easy to use.
How you do it is,
you pull right here on the side
to remove the lid.
Mm‐hmm. Okay.
The second step is,
raise the handle
to the raised position.
And then, it's like
the guillotine.
I just made a nice thick
slice, though, I think.
And then you got
a perfect slice.
Oh, and then it's like
a little escal‐‐
Yep.
Like a little, like,
moving sidewalk.
Yep.
The wheels move it.
And then, so, how to know
how thick or how thin
your slice?
You just kind of
eyeball it on the side?
Yeah, you just eyeball it.
And that was one
of the things we've learned
talking to customers.
I'm gonna try
to do a big one.
A lot of people have
a big preference
of thin slice
or thick slice.
So, what do you do about
the wheel when it comes off?
[ Laughs ] The wheel
shouldn't come off.
It does snap
back together.
It does? Okay.
Tell you, this a very thin
slice of cheese.
It's good.
Okay, wait, this came
completely out.
Just push it right back in?
Yep, you push it
right back in.
That's actually
how you swap handles.
So, in the bag,
you've got handles
with a grater, a blade,
and the wire.
Can you tell me how
you came up with the idea?
This came about ‐‐
I was living on the river
with a bunch of buddies,
and we ‐‐
Living on a river.
Oh, man.
It was on
the Willamette River.
We were the poorest people
on the river by tenfold
and had more fun
than everyone else combined.
Always.
Oh, it was great.
So, you know, naturally,
we've got the dock,
and we're barbecuing
all the time.
Sunday, we come
clean up the pigsty,
and there'd be half a brick
sitting there,
another quarter in the fridge
that no one put away.
We're like,
"Man, this is ridiculous."
And then, finally,
one afternoon,
we're sitting there
having a margarita.
All of a sudden,
screams from the kitchen.
My friend had
cut her finger...
[ Gasps ]
Corcoran: Oh, boy.
...chopping cheese.
So, we get her
kind of doctored up,
and we're like, "Guys,
there's gotta be a better way."
So, we looked
on the Internet,
and there was
absolutely nothing.
Mm.
So, we went
to the shop ‐‐
to my garage ‐‐ and the first
Cheese Chopper was born.
Greiner: Aww.
I love that.
And then I had
some old modeling clay and stuff
from some old projects we did,
so we put it all together.
I'm like, "Holy smokes,
this thing kind of works."
[ Laughing ]
This is the 39th prototype
we've gone through.
O'Leary: So, it's still a
prototype or are you actually ‐‐
39th?
No, I'm sorry. So ‐‐
Wait, wait.
39th?
Are you actually
shipping it?
39th.
Wow.
You're actually
shipping this product?
We're not currently
shipping it yet.
So, we have $125,000
in presales that we did.
This is at Kickstarter?
Was it Kickstarter, or...
Kickstarter, yeah.
So, we did a Kickstarter.
Started at the end of April.
We ended up raising ‐‐
This year?
This year.
So, this is pre‐sales,
pre‐shipping of the product.
Correct, but those are
out of our injection molds.
We hit couple speed bumps
just with COVID
and the manufacturing
and whatnot.
I got these three days
before I left for the show.
Scott: Really?
So, talk about
cutting it close.
You don't take ‐‐ You probably
know I'm Chef Wonderful.
There's lots of
alternative ways...
You do not sell cheese.
....to cut cheese.
Correct.
Number one,
as you know...
Here it goes.
...this device is sold
by itself to slice cheese.
Correct. The biggest
differentiation for us is,
we are the only one
that slices, shreds, and stores.
And we actually do have a
pending utility patent on that.
What's the price gonna be
of this product?
So, the retail price
on that is $39.99.
And that's delivered door ‐‐
And the cost to make it?
So, it costs me
$6.65 to make.
By the time you package,
ship it, land it,
we're at $8.30
landed in the warehouse.
Okay, so, when you went
and put this on Kickstarter,
how much did you
try to raise?
So, our goal was $15,000.
And how much did you do?
$100,436.
That's amazing.
Wow!
What do you think
brought all the traffic?
So, we drove a lot of it
with Instagram,
Facebook, social media,
but we also had ‐‐
the Kickstarter community
bought a lot.
Did they?
There was a lot of them.
Yeah, so, we've sold another
25 grand since Kickstarter.
Zero marketing,
zero advertising,
Word of mouth, people just
finding our website.
So, of the $125,000
in sales,
it's gonna cost us $47,000
to fulfill all those orders.
We've spent $29,000
on our marketing,
our content, our ad spend,
everything else,
which leaves us
$49,000 profit.
Tate, look, you know,
congratulations
on what you've done.
The challenge with
Kickstarter‐driven sales is,
you don't really have
a lot of customer feedback yet,
not even minimal
customer feedback, right?
Right.
Because you're waiting
for the first units.
And so,
the challenge there ‐‐
because you have to
deliver en masse,
if one little thing is wrong
or the customer expectation
doesn't match up
with what you deliver,
now, all of a sudden,
that $47,000
or whatever it is
in profit ‐‐ gone.
And not only
is that gone,
you've got to deal with
reputational issues.
You've got to figure out
how to solve the problem.
Things tend to cascade
very quickly
and go south very quickly.
And so, for those
reasons, I'm out.
All right.
Sorry to hear that,
but fair enough.
Tate, I would have loved to have
customer feedback on this.
No question, all right?
I know you're almost
pre‐revenue in the sense
that Kickstarter, to me,
doesn't mean much.
What matters to me
is a long history ‐‐
at least a year worth
of sales ‐‐
'cause I actually think
your price point of $39.95
is $10 too high.
Okay.
It's a $29.95 item.
Your competition is this.
I cut cheese like crazy
with this device
and a cylindrical
shredding device,
but they're really
inexpensive.
You know, the one thing
that it has merit for
that I'll give you is ‐‐ the
storage aspect is interesting.
Right.
The valuation's not crazy.
$750,000.
I just ‐‐ There's not
enough data here for me.
Okay, fair enough,
so just ‐‐
Sorry, I'm out.
Okay, fair enough.
Just to kind of
touch on ‐‐
Scott: You know, look...
Yep.
I'm the dairy state
girl over here.
I love cheese.
But I've got to tell you,
this needs some work.
When I was trying to do it,
it did get stuck.
And you may need
further testing,
further time to perfect it,
because on Mark's point,
if you don't have
the product right
and you ship it out too soon
and you disappoint
your customer, you've lost.
This product
has to be perfect.
For all of those
reasons, I'm out,
but I congratulate you
on taking that risk,
taking that chance.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Greiner: You know, let me
tell you a little story.
So, aerodynamically,
the bumblebee should not
be able to fly.
Its little wings are too small
for its fat little body,
but, yet,
the bumblebee flies.
[ Laughs ]
So, even if you don't
know something,
you will make it happen.
Unfortunately, here,
it's so early
that I can't be
your queen bee here.
But I know that you will
make things happen,
I know you will work it out,
and so, I wish you good luck,
but, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Corcoran: You know what's
great about you, Tate?
What's that?
For every 10 people
who have an idea,
one person maybe eventually
does something with it.
You saw it,
and the same day,
you turned around
and got it going,
and you actually
turned out a product.
And you raised funding
on Kickstarter.
There's probably
a thousand people
who couldn't do that,
so you've got a great start.
Right.
I think the weakness
to your product,
from my view as a consumer,
is that I love cheese,
and I typically have
four or five
kinds of cheeses
in my fridge.
Right.
And they probably all store
in that kind of space ‐‐
that much space.
So I can't envision myself
using all this space
to store one cheese,
and then having three or four
more in addition to that.
Okay.
And so, it's not a product
that appeals to me,
but that doesn't mean
it wouldn't appeal to everybody.
But I do commend you
how quickly you got it going,
and even though
you might leave here
being a little discouraged
that you didn't get our cash...
Right.
...it's only because
it's too early.
You haven't proved it yet.
But for those reasons,
because you're too early,
I am out.
Okay, fair enough.
Good luck, Tate. Man,
congrats on what you've done.
‐All right.
‐Yeah, good luck, Tate.
Keep working,
getting this going.
Corcoran: Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Yeah.
Have a good day.
Take care, Tate.
Wow.
‐Bye.
‐Bye‐bye.
Koenig: We're taking this
as a little bit of a speed bump.
It definitely sucks,
and it's kind of a kick
in the you‐know‐where,
but we're gonna
get through it.
We're gonna keep going
and keep chopping cheese.
Cuban: So, Lori, did we
really have to hear
the bumblebee story?
Don't you like hearing
about the bumblebee?
No, it's a stupid story.
It's not stupid!
Very bad story.
[ Laughter ]
What I wanted
to say was,
"This is never going to work.
It's going to go to zero,
and you've wasted your time."
What stopped you, Kevin?
Because I'm in
my anger‐management class.
It's not working.
I'm thinking about my tutor
and saying, "Yes.
Ohm."
Ohm.
Kevin.
Kevin, I'm surprised
you didn't just shred him.
I was going to.
Ohh!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product designed
to maximize
your counter space.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I am Melissa Clayton
from Acton, Massachusetts,
and I am so excited
to be here.
I am coming here today
asking for $100,000
for 20% equity
in my company, The Matte.
♪♪
If you were to ask
most women
at some point in their life
have put a hair dryer
on top of a toilet bowl,
and that's disgusting.
And they bounce their makeup
and their brushes
all around the edges
of the sink
because there's
no counter space,
and it's just waiting
for something to fall and break.
Greiner: [ Gasps ]
The entire process
of getting ready
is messy and unorganized
because there's
no counter space.
Well, that is literally
all about to change
with my product, The Matte.
I'm gonna clean this up,
and then I'm gonna show you.
♪♪
[ Objects clattering lightly ]
Introducing The Matte.
This simple, compact product
simply unfolds,
lays right over
your bathroom sink,
and creates an instant counter.
It can also hold
your hairbrush,
and it lays flat and sturdy.
And The Matte
can hold two pounds
of makeup and product.
The Matte also has
little ridges
so that your makeup
won't fall on the floor
and your brushes
will stay clean.
And, literally,
it will hold everything
that was just all over
that bathroom sink.
See? It's all there.
And then, the best part
about The Matte
is that it folds up
to the size of a tablet
for easy storage
and for travel.
Sharks, The Matte is
an absolute game‐changer
for the millions and millions
of women
getting ready in bathrooms
with no counter space.
So, now, who is getting ready
to give me a deal?
So, Melissa,
tell us about you.
So, when I came up with
the idea for The Matte,
I had already
started another company,
and the entire time
I was building that company,
I was always working
on The Matte.
And I'm proud to say that
the other company that I started
is actually what supports
my family now.
What's your other company?
What is your
other company?
So, my other company,
we do fine personalized
jewelry for moms.
So, Kendra,
you're kind of my idol.
Aww!
So I'm honored to be
with you here today.
That company, I have a team now
with nine people
and doesn't need me
the way they used to need me.
This is ‐‐ This is ‐‐
No.
In the last ‐‐
You don't have
all this products!
Kevin ‐‐ "No."
In the last 30 days,
we have sold $20,000 worth
of this product.
What's your total sales,
lifetime?
About $200,000.
And when did you start?
I started ‐‐
Really, that's three years
that we've been
selling The Matte.
Three years.
So, $200,000
in three years.
Yeah.
Okay.
And where are you
selling the product?
So, we do Amazon,
our own website,
and one third‐party retailer.
And last year,
we did $85,000 in revenue.
We sell it for $24.99,
and it costs $7 landed.
Melissa, I haven't
even bought it,
and I want my money back.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
It's definitely
a product, I think,
that women understand
better than men.
On this product
and this opportunity,
all I see is a barn...
...so I'm out.
I understand.
Thank you for your time.
Look, this is great.
I have a 17‐
and a 14‐year‐old daughter,
and so, I see it
in their rooms.
I think you're amazing,
but it's just not a fit for me,
so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations,
Melissa.
Thanks for your time, Mark.
I appreciate it.
No, thank you.
Are you doing
advertising?
Are you doing ‐‐
No advertising at all.
None at all?
Not at all.
Well, then, how did you get
$200,000 in sales?
From word of mouth
and from working
with different influencers.
I think there's
a need for it.
I'm curious as to whether
you have other competition.
There's nothing else like it
out there on the market,
and we have a patent on it.
Melissa, when I was a kid,
we had 10 kids
and one bathroom.
Oh, my gosh.
We each had
our own plastic ‐‐
like a cafeteria tray,
and we were not allowed
to go into the bathroom
without our tray.
Wow.
So I don't agree that
you don't have something here.
I think this is a problem.
I think it's well‐designed.
But, I mean, it's not
something I find investable.
But I wouldn't want you
to be discouraged.
So I sadly go out.
Thanks.
I appreciate it, Barbara.
I have three sisters.
Four girls, okay?
We shared one bathroom
growing up.
So it was two sinks
and very little
counter space in between.
And guess who's
the youngest.
You.
Me, meaning that
I had nothing.
I think I was on the floor
picking out my mascara.
So, this could be something
that would be super cool.
My problem is, though,
is when I saw this,
I thought it was for
a tablet or notebook.
The name "The Matte"
did not at all register with me
at all what you were solving.
I think you're onto something,
but I'm just not there yet,
and for that reason,
unfortunately,
I've gotta say I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate your time.
Lori, I feel like
you and me could
do something amazing
with this product.
I think hotels.
I think college dorms, RVs.
I mean, there's
50 million apartments.
There's 5 million
hotel rooms.
I think branding
The Matte and licensing ‐‐
there's a lot
of opportunity there.
I have made tons of cosmetic
organizers over the years.
The biggest problem
is organization
and mess and space.
So, women usually
have tons of makeup.
It's all over the place.
You have a small apartment.
I mean, you don't
have a lot of room.
You need another countertop.
So I see opportunity here.
Are you kidding me?
Thank you.
I also see that there's a lot
of work I'm going to have to do.
I'm gonna give you an offer.
So, I'll give you
$100,000,
but I want to be
a 33 1/3% partner.
♪♪
Your evaluation
just got demolished.
♪♪
Lori, I think that
you and I together
would do amazing things
with this product.
I did feel my valuation
was reasonable
with the utility patent
and the skills I bring.
What?
Would you consider 25%?
You know, I love you, Melissa,
and I love your product,
but I think I need to be
a third partner.
I really do, because I need
to get in there.
I need to give you
the muscle and the hustle,
and I want to do it,
and I want to
blow it up for you.
♪♪
Lori, I trust you.
I believe you.
Let's do a deal!
Whoo!
Corcoran: Wow!
Scott:
A great decision.
Greiner: Yay!
Great decision.
Thank you so much!
I appreciate all your time.
Corcoran: Nice going.
Congratulations.
Thanks, Melissa.
Congrats, Melissa.
♪♪
Clayton: I gave up more equity
to Lori than I had hoped for,
but in the end,
I am just so thrilled
to do a deal with her.
I think it's just
gonna be amazing.
A moment of silence
for $100,000
that just lost its life.
You have no idea.
You don't wear makeup.
Yes, he does.
Please, Lori,
respect the money.
I'm taking your Matte.
It died.
It had a horrible death.
Please.
[ Laughing ]
It did not.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a solution
for a problem
of pet ownership.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name
is Harry Levin!
And I'm Michael Sweigart,
inventor of the FurZapper,
the first pet hair remover
for your washer and your dryer.
We are both from New Jersey
and are asking for $600,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
Hello.
Whoa.
Levin: Hello, Sharks!
This is the amazing
FurZapper.
It is the best and only
patented pet hair remover
that solves the problem
every pet owner has.
Pet owners, you have
a huge and hairy problem.
You put your clothes
into the washer,
and they come
out of the dryer...
looking like this ‐‐
still covered in pet hair.
Ugh!
Pet hair, fur,
lint, and dander
sticks to your laundry,
even after you wash it
and dry it many, many times.
Sweigart: We have solved this
problem with the FurZapper,
the world's only
pet hair remover
that works in your washer
and your dryer.
So, here's how it works.
Simply take your FurZappers
and add them into your washer.
♪♪
So, FurZapper's tacky surface
grabs onto pet hair,
dislodges it,
and washes it down the drain.
But there's more ‐‐
in the dryer, FurZapper grabs
any remaining pet hair
and puts it right
into your lint trap,
giving you fur‐free laundry
every time.
It's really that good, huh?
That's great.
Honest to God!
I believe you.
[ Laughs ]
And, Sharks, the best
part is this ‐‐
you can reuse FurZapper
over and over and over
and over again.
So, Sharks, with your help,
we'll be zapping the fur
off of pet owners' clothes
around the world.
And as we say...
"Shed happens!"
Okay, guys,
quick question.
When I do my laundry
and I just throw
everything in there ‐‐
You do your own laundry?
Yes, of course.
No, he doesn't.
Yes, of course I do.
When Mark is at home
doing everyone's laundry...
Not everybody's.
Just mine.
If only one or two pieces have
our dog's hair on it ‐‐ right ‐‐
that's fine ‐‐ I don't have to
segregate them all?
No, no, no, no.
So I just
put it in there.
It knows which is which.
That's cool.
You throw it in there,
and because it has
holes in it ‐‐
so it allows the holes
to touch the clothing.
And as it touches
the clothing,
since it's made of silicone,
it's tacky initially.
Yeah, I mean, watch.
Like, I was
playing with it.
Yep, it's great.
Look at that.
Okay, how did you
come up with this idea?
So, I've been, like,
a work‐at‐home dad
for 15 ‐‐
almost 20 years.
So I would do the laundry,
and I'd pull out the laundry,
and the stuff would be dry.
And I'd be folding it,
and it still had pet hair on it.
I accidentally
found the solution.
I had done some work in, like,
the special‐effects industry,
more as a hobby.
I had a silicone
zombie mask ‐‐
like, no joke ‐‐
and it was ripped.
And I dropped it
on the floor,
and I noticed that
my dog and cat's hair was on it.
And I said, "Whoa, that's ‐‐
something's going on here."
So I threw it in the washer,
and it was the most effective
thing I'd ever used.
Corcoran: Wow.
That's great.
What a great story.
That is such a good story!
Greiner: Interesting.
So you figured it out
by chance.
Sweigart: Yep.
How did you two meet?
So, Michael and I
were members
of the same business
networking group.
So, I have a keen interest
in animal welfare.
I also happened to be
a lawyer for 40 years.
So, we got together,
we started talking,
and there was
just a chemistry.
O'Leary:
All right, guys, look,
you're asking
for $600,000 for 10% ‐‐
imputes a $6 million
valuation.
Yes, sir.
How much are you selling?
Well, in our first year,
which was a partial year ‐‐
it was '18 ‐‐
we did $640,000 in sales.
Last year, we did
$2.2 million...
Whoo!
Wow.
What did you make
on the $2.2 million?
We made $580,000.
Wow!
That's after you
paid yourself something?
That's with salaries
out of that.
'Cause I was gonna say...
[ High‐pitched voice ]
"Oh, no, there's no sales!"
Oh, no, there's sales!
There are sales!
[ Normal voice ]
But there are.
Even with COVID
here now...
Yeah.
Like, we had ‐‐
we had expected
a $5 million year,
but we're gonna do over
$4 million this year.
We're already on track.
And where are you
selling it?
Actually,
our first deal was ‐‐
Walmart was actually
our first customer.
‐Wow.
And we are in every Walmart
in the entire country.
Every single one?
Dang!
Every one.
That's a
"Shark Tank" first.
Wow!
And our margins
on our two‐pack ‐‐
which is our top seller ‐‐
This one.
Yeah, that's
the majority. Yep.
Okay.
That's right. 71%.
Yep.
What?!
What does the
two‐pack sell for?
What's the retail?
Levin: $14.99.
Wow.
And I want you
to know this ‐‐
our acquisition cost ‐‐
you sittin' down? ‐‐
ha‐ha ‐‐ a nickel!
Wow!
It costs a nickel
to sell a product.
Fantastic.
We've been on QVC.
Yeah, what happened
when you were on QVC?
Well, you know what?
We got on QVC.
They showed us, Lori,
at 3:00 in the morning.
Yeah.
'Cause you weren't
with me, Harry.
Well, that's what
I'm saying!
Cuban: So, guys, what are you
gonna use the money for?
Okay,
love that question.
What we're doing is ‐‐
Our biggest challenge
has been the fact
that we have had
to outsource manufacturing.
Although we have patents
in the United States,
Canada, China,
and all
the European Union countries,
dealing with
a United States manufacturer
is just too expensive.
So, what we're gonna use every
dollar of the investment is,
bringing manufacturing
in‐house...
There you go!
...which we already
know how to do...
Yeah.
There you go.
...and cut out
$2 of our profit...
Yep.
...bring it back in‐house.
It gives jobs...
Yep.
...and it allows us
to be able...
Yep.
...to continue to produce
in the United States.
You say you're gonna build,
in essence, your own facility?
That's correct, Barbara.
Okay, guys, let me
take a shot at this...
Sure, please.
...because I like deals
with sales...
Sure.
And I'm in the cat
business ‐‐ Basepaws.
We do cat DNA testing,
and I have all their names,
e‐mail addresses, et cetera.
I'd love to sell this
direct to those customers, okay?
I'm gonna make
a two‐part offer to you
so you can choose
which way you want to go.
This business is so successful
in terms of free cash flow
that it can support debt,
so I'll offer you $600,000
for debt for three years
at 9.5%,
and I'll only take 5% equity
in that scenario, okay?
And then,
if you want to go equity,
I'll do the $600,000
for 20%.
Then, I go to work
expanding what you're doing
direct to customer.
That, to me,
is far more interesting,
because the margins
are obscene.
There's an offer
to put some fur on.
Anybody else, please?
Corcoran: Well, I'm curious
what you think about that offer.
It's a brilliant offer.
There's no two ways
about it.
That's 'cause
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
Not so brilliant, Harry.
Levin:
And you know what?
Today, you have underscored
your reputation.
But I am very interested in
hearing from your colleagues.
I'm sure you are.
As you should be.
Of course. That's why ‐‐
I'm from New Jersey! Come on!
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran:
Wait, wait, wait.
I'd like to
make you an offer.
I think I could take your sales
to the moon and back,
much like I have done
with Comfy.
They have $250 million
in sales.
In Costco alone, we're doing
$30 million in Comfys.
Ah!
Okay.
What we're about to do
with Comfy is do an infomercial,
and I happen to think
you should be doing it, too.
Yeah.
You're, like,
made for TV.
I'd like to give you
$600,000 for 20%.
Thank you.
Scott: You know what?
I have fallen in love
with you both,
but as I'm sitting here
in the Tank today ‐‐
Look, there are things
that I'm great at,
but some of these Sharks
have access to give you things
that I could not.
I'm going to pass
because I know
it's better for you,
but if one of these Sharks
let me in a little bit,
I sure as heck
would like to invest.
But for that reason,
I'm out.
I think that you've got
great options here,
so listen to them all.
I respect that. Yeah.
Okay, do you know that,
every single year,
I bring my same pad?
I scribble my notes.
In all these years,
I have never sat
and written one thing.
I wrote,
"This is so right for me."
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Michael and Harry have
two offers on the table
for their laundry pet hair
remover, FurZapper,
but Lori
is also interested.
Greiner:
Wait a minute.
Do you know that,
every single year,
I bring my same pad?
I scribble my notes.
In all these years,
I have never sat
and written one thing.
I wrote,
"This is so right for me."
Lori, that's funny.
I wrote, "It's better for me."
I ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: No, this is
so right for me.
I mean, it's in my bones,
right?
So, I would give you
the $600,000.
And I want you to feel good,
so I'm going to give it
for 19.99%.
‐Ohh!
‐Whoa!
Cuban: Whoa!
God.
19.99%.
Oh, my God.
O'Leary:
That is so corny.
I'll do it for 15%, guys.
$600,000 for 15%?
You'll do it for 15%?
15%.
No, Harry.
Wait a sec.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Harry.
$600,000 for 15%.
Wait a sec.
Harry.
Lori.
Lori, let him
make an offer.
Michael.
No, we need to.
I'm listening.
Lori, listen, listen.
We need to do this
together, Harry.
You ‐‐ you're the queen,
and I'm not blowing smoke
at you,
but I've gotta
talk to Mark.
No, don't talk
to Mark, Harry.
Lori ‐‐
Don't talk to Mark, Harry.
Do you want to match
his offer, Lori, or not?
You need me. You want me.
Do you want to match
his 15%?
If I walk out of this ‐‐
If I walk out of here
and I don't talk to this man,
my wife
is going to cut me off.
[ Laughing ]
All right?
So I gotta talk to Mark.
Yeah, but do you want me
as your partner?
$600,000 ‐‐
Let him talk to Mark!
Lori, relax.
$600,000, 15%.
We do. We do.
Will you jump in
with him?
I won't jump in with him,
but I'll match it, Harry.
I'll give you $600,000...
Oh, wow.
Oh, it's getting
intense in here.
...for 15%,
but you have to pick me.
I'm the right partner for you,
and if you don't know that...
No, no, no, no, no ‐‐
I'm going to blow you up
internationally,
U.S.A., everywhere.
♪♪
Barbara, what can I do
to get you in this deal?
Cuban: Wait, wait, wait.
Well, hold on, guys.
Hold on, guys, right?
When you say to Barb,
"What can I do
to get you in?"
What are you trying to get to?
What's your goal?
Greiner: Why are you trying
to get more people in?
'Cause sometimes
that's not the best deal.
Corcoran: He just wants ‐‐
Listen, he wants to know
he's got the best deal.
He's a businessman.
No, sometimes
it's not the best deal.
Listen, we ‐‐
Sometimes when
the Sharks work alone,
you can just
hit the ground running and race.
♪♪
Okay, guys,
Mark and Lori at 15%,
Barbara and I at 20%
on the equity.
The only debt offer's mine.
Yes.
$600,000 plus the 5% equity.
No, I think I'm gonna
go down to 15%, as well,
and I'm gonna give you
another $600,000 credit line.
♪♪
What are you gonna do?
Lori, if you go to 15%
for $600,000
with the understanding that
you're going to have to provide
some additional finance
if we need it...
we're okay.
Good!
Lori, you have a deal!
Yeah, whoo!
Cuban: There you go.
Whoop‐whoop‐whoop!
15%! Hey!
Thank you.
I am so glad!
Congratulations.
Thanks so much!
Thank you.
Corcoran:
Congratulations, Lori.
Nicely done.
Lori, it was
perfect for you.
[ Laughs ]
We did it.
I have been watching Lori
on "Shark Tank"
for all of the seasons,
and I've fallen in love
with her,
and I respect
everything she does.
So making a deal with her ‐‐
other than getting married,
the birth of my children
and my grandchildren ‐‐
this is, without a doubt,
the best day of my life.
♪♪